fundamentally
if people understand that the source of
human experience is within you
joy or misery agony or ecstasy pleasure
or pain
everything comes from within you if you
understand this much
if i understand suppose right now i
think i'm miserable because of you
there's no solution for my life isn't it
because all you have to do is walk in
front of my home i will become miserable
so simple it is you don't have to kill
me you just have to walk around in front
of me i will
die within myself every day if i
understand the source of my joy and
misery are within me
then you know what's the obvious choice
joy it's obvious choice isn't it
so this one fundamental thing has to get
across to all the human beings on this
planet
your experience is entirely determined
by you
this is what the word karma means
unfortunately it becomes something else
here
karma means action that means
when we say your life is your karma we
are saying your life is entirely your
making
100 percent what happens in the world
there are many many forces involved what
happens within me
it's 100 me 100
isn't it yes if you don't take charge of
this
then you're an accidental life when
you're an accident in life
anxiety is very natural
naturally suppose you're driving
accidentally that is you don't know
what's happening
and you're simply somehow going anxiety
is natural or no
yes any accidental moment
creates anxiety so this is why
consciousness means
this that you have taken charge
of the instruments of life which on most
fundamental level
is our physiological and psychological
space you take in charge of this
now your health your happiness your joy
your ecstasy your misery everything is
in your hands
you exercise them as you want fear is
always about
what may happen or may not happen right
fear is not about what is what we are
experiencing right now
what will happen is always the fear
or in other words your fear is about
something which is not yet
your fear is about something which does
not exist
this is all management people if there
were a few
somebody from a psychiatric department
you could have asked them
if i have fear about something that does
not exist
what is my condition they would have a
title for you
yes nimhans is close by i think we can
always consult that is also a premier
institution
[Music]
we are suffering something which doesn't
even exist
[Music]
yes if you are suffering something that
doesn't even exist
it is not about life it is not about
education it's not about
career it is just about your mind being
out of control
is that not an important aspect that you
should manage first before
we allow you to manage an industry or a
business is it not important first of
all you learn to at least
manage your mind hello
isn't it important if you do not know
how to manage your mind what the hell
are you going to manage in the world
managers are all freaking out and
growing ulcers
in their stomachs yes today it's become
normal
if you are a ceo by 45 if you don't have
an ulcer you're not a great ceo
because you are managing
by accident like this the fear comes
because there is an accidental
possibility
isn't it tell me let's say you don't
know how to ride a bicycle
you sat on it it was on stand you were
just pedaling for fun
and it came off stand and started
rolling anxiety or
[Music]
started rolling faster fear or no very
fast
terror or no it's not because bicycle
produces terror
it is just that you don't know how to
ride
if you know how to ride faster it goes
the better it is
isn't it faster it goes the better it is
the very
very uh basis why we created a bicycle
is because we wanted to go faster than
walking
that's an idea but if you do not know
how to write
how much fear it creates right now your
problem is not with the world your
problem is not with your education
your problem is your education system
right from kindergarten hasn't told you
a damn thing
about how to manage yourself see there
is uh
scientific evidence to show at least 20
percent of your energy
right now as you sit here in a restful
state
is being consumed by your brain
if you bring this down
that your brain is not unnecessarily
fluctuating and
you know hopping
all the time if it learns to still
be still and do only what's needed
an enormous sense of personal power will
develop
you can't do this with your mind right
now if you try to stop it it'll hop
even more crazy at least do it with your
body
your words and your physical movements
reduce it by 50
if you want to look at this look at this
you want to look at that look at that
don't do this this this
with your body and your utterances if
you do this
slowly it will also start manifesting in
your mind it will not do
unnecessary things when you don't know
unnecessary things
the energy that you have slowly
transforms itself into potential power
you cannot pursue enlightenment
how can you pursue something that you do
not know
if you pursue something you will pursue
only what you know
what is the point pursuing something
that you already know
what is the point in running after
something that you already know
so if you have to step into something
that you do not know
the only thing is just to keep walking
keep a steady direction and keep working
maybe it's the wrong direction
it doesn't matter just keep walking
after all planet is round
inevitably if you keep walking
and keep straight walking not round and
round
if you just keep straight walking you
will inevitably get somewhere
nobody can take it away from you
you know if you have a dog at home you
would know this
if you just tickle him in the tail he
will go
sh chasing his own tail
okay a lot of people are doing that
their own tail they're chasing even
enlightenment is their own tale
nobody told you there is such a thing
but definitely you can see
from one person to another person one
person seems to be little better off
simply the way they are not because of
their money not because of their wealth
not because of their qualifications
simply the way they sit and stand
somebody seems to be better off than
somebody else
yes or no
[Music]
so there is room and scope for
improvement
relentlessly improve let's see where it
gets you
but if you have fancy ideas of what is
enlightenment
then you will chase that silly idea
and that idea is never enlightenment
because it's your idea
see right now what are the instruments
of your experience
you know you're here only because you
can see
hear smell taste and touch this is the
only way you know that you're here right
now
suppose your toes off don't okay suppose
you doze off
you don't know that you're here isn't it
yes
even though you're here your heart is
beating everything is functioning the
world is on we are all here
but you won't know that you're here nor
will you know that i am here or anybody
else is here
isn't it yes all that's happened is life
is on full-on even within you
only thing is these five sensory organs
have shut down
so your entire experience of life right
now is happening because you can see
here
smell taste and touch just look at the
nature of the sensory organs in the very
nature
they're outward bound isn't it
can you roll your eyeballs inward and
scan yourself
no this is a
shall i give you a bad example sorry
your our nose is located nice right
above our mouth
suppose you don't brush your teeth for
three days
[Music]
though this nose is right here it won't
tell you you have not brushed your teeth
the whole room will know you have not
brushed your teeth but you will not know
this is the human predicament
it's very easy to see what's wrong with
this guy what's wrong with her what's
wrong with her
it's very it takes a lot of observation
to see what's wrong with this
that level of keenness of observation is
missing in most people
they need to cultivate that see as we
sit here
this is my body that is your body do
what you want
these two things will not become one
this is my mind that is your mind do
what you want these things
will not become one they may overlap on
some issues
and we may feel that we are one with
each other but
my mind is my mind your mind is your
mind isn't it
but there is no such thing as my life
and your life
this is a living cosmos you captured a
little bit
i captured a little bit that's about it
but now we think this is my life and
that is your life there is no such thing
this is a living cosmos you've blown a
small bubble
somebody might have blown a little
bigger bubble
did you glow soap bubbles when you were
young oh yeah you still do
so when you blew soap bubbles
somebody had this big bubble somebody
else had that big bubble
oh went on saying this is my bubble this
your bubble
but poop it went once it goes poop
you did not say this is my hair and this
is your hair
similarly there is no such thing as my
life and your life
there is just a living cosmos if you
capture
more life then you will see
you have more grace the depth dimension
and scope of your life is determined by
how much life you capture
within you it doesn't matter what kind
of body you have
what kind of intelligence you have if
you have not
captured substantial life within you you
will live a small life
that's how it is how do you do this
there are systematic ways of approaching
this
or simply by involvement and exuberance
by commitment people may capture a
larger life
by absolutely being committed to
something focused on something
somebody may capture a certain amount of
life which is more
than what is considered normal this
happened in 1941
this is just when the nazi movement was
building up in germany and
in some parts of europe so one day in
austria
a bunch of german soldiers came broke
into the homes
the jewish family a rich family they
broke the home
and took away the adults took everything
was robbed
and these two children a 12 year old
girl and an eight-year-old boy were
taken away
they were taken to a railway station
this the month of nowhere and december
kind of time
when it's becoming very cold so they
were kept on the railway station for
three days because the trains did not
come
boys little boys being boys they started
playing football
so they were playing football and then
suddenly the train came
the train is not a passenger train it's
a cargo train a good stream
so when the train came the soldiers came
and rushed everybody
into the the wagons which are there
everybody got in and the little boy and
the girl also got in
but the little boy forgot to wear his
shoes he left his shoes outside
and they pushed him into the wagon so
without shoes he came
his sister a 12 year old girl
saw her kid brother coming without
shoes and she got mad with him she held
him by the year
boxed his ears scolded him nicely
slapped him
say you eat it already we are in enough
trouble
now you come without shoes because in
germany in winter no shoes means you may
lose your feet
so she's angry about that in the next
station the boys and girls were
separated
after four years after the war was over
she came out of the concentration camp
to find
17 members of her family including
her little brother all had vanished
no records no sign of them they just
evaporated
at that time the only thing that
bothered her was
the last few things that she said to her
little brother
she loves her brother but the last few
things that she said to him
were such terrible things it rang in her
mind
and troubled her these are the last
things i told my brother and after that
i'm never going to see him is gone
so she took a wow if i speak to anybody
in my life
i will speak in such a way if this is my
last word
i will not regret
this one thing transformed her life in
such a way
she went on to united states she died in
2006
she did some phenomenal work built a
hospital
somewhere near chicago i think
she lived a fruitful life i'm saying
even if you
put through the most horrible situations
[Music]
either you can come out using that
experience as a better human being
or you can use the experience to become
a horrible mess
so whenever something hurts you there
are two
options you can either become wounded
or you can become wise this is the
choice
the more things hurt you early on in
your life
the wiser you should have become isn't
it
but unfortunately most people become
wounded
this is simply because they just need an
excuse
to turn their own intelligence against
themselves that's all
especially if the world around you turns
against you
is it not very very important that your
intelligence stands up for you
you tell the story of a man who had
wings
but never used them to fly and just
reproduce and had a life
and isn't it a tragedy that he'd never
use his wings to fly
do you feel like most of us are walking
through life with wings and we never use
them to fly
unfortunately yes a whole lot of people
too many people
it's time that human potential is
unleashed because we are the first
generation on the planet
for whom our survival is organized
better than ever before
ever so this is the time
to unlock our potential to lose those
all kinds of inhibitions and fears
that we had there was a time if as much
as a cloud gathered and
uh lightning and thunder happened we
thought god was angry with us
okay okay all those things are gone
it is time you take away the nonsense
that's happening within you
and the entire process the science of
inner engineering is just
this how to work at it in a scientific
manner
not with philosophy i can tell you a
thousand times give up your fear it's
not going to go
but if your chemical soup is blissful
there's not even a
idea of fear in your mind
it reminds me of your concept of the
movies you play the movies in your mind
you can choose a drama you can choose a
horror story or you can choose
a positive movie and not get stuck in
the same movie
forever you can turn it off and start a
new one
yeah but for that you should know where
the switches are
right you are like a super computer
but you haven't found the keyboard yet
time to find the keyboard
that's my work to give people the
keyboard to their super computer
around us so many people will do so many
things that we don't like
yes or no so many things in mumbai
happening
things that we don't like are everyday
happening
but at least within you only what you
want should happen within this
isn't it
i cannot decide that only what i want
should happen with you
but i can definitely decide only what i
want must happen within me isn't it
if you could decide only what you want
should
happen within you would you choose anger
or joy what's your choice please choose
i'm going to bless you
see you want the highest level of
pleasantness for yourself
isn't it then why is such a thing not
happening
as i said earlier you never read the
user's manual
how this functions has not been looked
at do not go by the example of people
who came here a few
few years earlier than you that
no no my mother also was like that my
grandmother also was getting angry so i
am also getting angry
they should not be the leading lights of
your life
i want you to look at it your thought
your emotion your body
must happen the way you want isn't it
[Music]
if somebody else can decide what should
happen within you
this is ultimate slavery isn't it so
what happens around you maybe we can
decide
but nobody should decide except yourself
what happens within you
if you decide you would keep this in the
high state of pleasantness for sure
you wouldn't be battling with anger it's
not just about
anger fear stress tension don't address
them separately
essentially your mind is not taking
instructions from you
why because you don't know where the
damn keyboard is
yet we gave you a super computer
you do not know where where the keyboard
is so one day you did this something
worked
another day you did this something
worked you know have you seen people
the radio doesn't work boom and it works
sometimes
that's not a technology that's chance
have you seen this if something doesn't
work people think tupped up
tough it'll work and a lot of people are
using this for human beings also
how to address the larger issues of my
life
there are no large issues in your life
somebody needs to help me understand
that
what is the large issue that you're
talking about it is just about
what job to take which girl to marry
where to go for vacation
whether whether to get married or not
get married you know
these are things isn't it these are not
large issues these are little things in
your life
yes oh is it just a small thing whom i
get married to
i'm not saying it's a small thing but as
an issue it's a small issue
little issue as a consequence to your
life yes it has many things
but this is something that human beings
have done for
millions of years we have enough
experience on these things isn't it
we know that whatever job we take
whoever we marry
[Music]
it is just the way we make out of it
every experience of life you can make it
an enriching experience
every experience in your life you can
make a curse out of it
see there is nothing wrong
in your job whatever job you're doing
there's nothing wrong getting this job
there's nothing along
wrong in losing this job there's nothing
wrong in getting married there's nothing
wrong in getting divorced
there's nothing wrong in not getting
married
there is nothing wrong in anything there
is nothing wrong in this or that
but it is just that you make misery out
of it
that's wrong
[Music]
if you do this you make misery out of it
if you do that you make misery out of it
that's what is wrong with you
so you got married is it wrong that's
not the point
there's nothing wrong with it you did
not get married is it wrong
no there's nothing wrong with it that's
wonderful too you got divorced is it
wrong
no that's also wonderful it is just that
you make misery out of everything that's
what is wrong
you just address that one issue
everything will be settled
all human experience is generated from
within is that
all human experience is generated from
within
so at any time if you feel happy or
unhappy
miserable joyful ecstatic
in a state of agony doesn't matter what
happens
what is your experience pleasantness or
unpleasantness
just to know that it's happening from
within
and it can only happen from within
you can either take external stimuli
or you can create your own stimuli but
essentially
it happens from within
this one thing if it is not grasped
when you feel miserable if you think
it's this one
you're gone you're you just
the keyboard is here but you're punching
the wall
it's not gonna work this one basic
fundamental thing
is something that almost 90 percent of
the humanity is always doing it wrong
whenever they feel miserable it they
think it must be this one or that one or
that one or
that one now
all human experiences generated from
within
if something is feeling unpleasant
first thing is to look at this what am i
doing wrong with this
am i eating wrong am i sleeping wrong am
i sitting wrong
am i breathing wrong is my heart beating
wrong something
my very chemistry is wrong something is
wrong with this
not with that
so the moment you think by kicking the
wall you can fix this one
then you made a fundamental mistake the
harder you try
the further away from it you go the
first thing is to bring balance
once there is balance then you can build
a tower on top of this
if there is no balance whatever you
build will only lead to more trouble
the more basic you are the better it is
so this is what a whole lot of humanity
is seeking
somehow to remain basic because if you
build something
it feels terrible when there is no
fundamental balance
anything standing up without balance is
a big problem
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check out my
training right here below
if you want to see the affirmations
video we did with ed milette check it
out right there next to me
i think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and i'll see you there